ladies and gentlemen remain standing for
the oath of office followed by musical
honors
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do
solemnly swear i kamala davey harrison
that i will support and defend the
constitution of the united states that i
will support
and defend the constitution against
all enemies foreign and domestic against
all enemies
born and domestic that i will bear true
faith
and allegiance
that i take this obligation freely that
i take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge
that i will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office on
which i am about to enter the duties of
the office
upon which i am about to enter so help
me god
so help me god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so america has its first female
vice president first woman of african
american
and south asian heritage
in the role